Hi, we are almost there as a next step. We need to go to the website. I see I'll express
This is the website that provides information about energy demand in the new England
And we need to create the account here
You need to sign up using your email and create the password since I already have
this account information
We need to store this information inside our system. Let me show you. I will clear these things up
Okay, yeah, we need to enter this comment
nano.env.example
Okay
So there is a specific file called .env.example
Where we need to store our credentials that we just created. So we need to store our email and password
so my email is
Please don't spam me and here is my password
I will not show you my password, but let's assume that I entered here some password, right?
password from my account
What is next? When I did this, right? I entered my password. I need to click control plus X
control X
I need to press Y
Yes, and here I need to rename the file
and I will just delete the .example and I will leave .env like here and I need to
To press enter and one more time I need to press Y. Yes
Okay
That's great
Okay, I will take a pause here and we will go to the final step of really
Making the minor run on the decentralized network. How cool is that?